President Trump is saying one thing
about undocumented immigrants but
officials along the border are now doing
something else
the president used fiery language to
excite his political base at a campaign
rally in South Carolina last night he
repeated his call to take away due
process rights for illegal immigrants I
said today I don't want judges I want
ice and Border Patrol agents esterday
but his administration is sending mixed
messages on zero-tolerance Customs and
Border Protection announced yesterday it
would stop referring undocumented
immigrants with children for prosecution
major Garrett is at the White House to
help sort through all of this major good
morning
well good morning the president was in
South Carolina his speech however was
all over the map he knocked late-night
comedians and the news media nurse
long-simmering fuse with some fellow
Republicans on Capitol Hill exaggerated
trade statistics and said he had great
political instincts telling the crowd
that he had to to his own horn because
nobody else would do it for him by the
way I have these stupid teleprompters
president Trump tore up the script at a
campaign rally in South Carolina and
described his enthusiastic supporters as
a new political force you're better
you're more loyal we have the greatest
base you know what you are you're the
super elite even as House Republicans
struggle to pass an immigration bill and
Democrats appear eager to stoke the
controversy the president jumped on some
Democratic calls to abolish immigration
and customs enforcement calls that only
a handful of Democrats have made
Democrats don't like ice they don't like
Border Patrol they don't like your
police they don't like anybody the
Democrats want to protect illegals
coming into this country and even though
funding remains in doubt there came the
familiar border wall chant
and promise it's not build that wall
anymore it's continue building that wall
because my building
hours earlier the president struck a
more empathetic tone about separated
families at the border we want children
staying together but mixed
administration signals continued as
Attorney General Jeff Sessions said the
zero tolerance policy for border
crossers remained we're going to
continue to prosecute those adults who
enter here illegally even as Border
Patrol said it stopped referring
undocumented immigrants with children
last week for prosecution what we have
is two extremes and I liked when it
comes to immigration and actually
governing there is this House Republican
bill that's supposed to be voted on
later this week the White House fears
House Republicans don't have enough
votes to pass it House Republican
leaders would like a stronger White
House endorsement to help get those
votes Gale that's what you call in
politics catch-22 all right major you
always put it in perspective thank you
so much